لماذا يذهب شخص ما إلى chatbot
للإبلاغ عن التحرش الجنسي وليس شخصًا
أو صديقًا أو بريدًا إلكترونيًا خاصًا ،
يجد الأشخاص أنه من المحرج حقًا التحدث إلى
إنسان حول التحرش فهم ليسوا
متأكدين مما إذا كان هناك شيء ما يعتبر
تحرشًا في بعض الأحيان
لست متأكدًا مما إذا كانوا يريدون تصعيد
شيء ما على الفور وقد يرغبون
في الجلوس عليه لفترة من الوقت ، يمكنك التحدث إلى
هذا الروبوت وعمل سجل مفصل
لما حدث ، ونأمل أن
تطرح الروبوتات عليك أسئلة قد لا
تفكر فيها  بمفردك ، يمكن أن يطلب منك قسم الموارد البشرية أن
يسألك ، إنه في الواقع يعتمد على
أفضل الممارسات في مقابلات الشرطة
وهي أسئلة مفتوحة ليست
أسئلة إرشادية ، فهو يتأكد من حصولك على أكبر
قدر ممكن من المعلومات
التي يمكن أن يكون من السهل تفويتها ثم
وضعها على  ورقة أعطني مثالاً على
سؤال قد يسألني روبوت الدردشة إذا
كان هناك شهود هل هناك
دليل آخر على أن هذا
حدث في أي وقت وتاريخ حدث هذا
بالضبط  كيف ترى شخصًا
يستخدمه ثم يقدمه إلى الأمام
، يبدأون محادثتهم المجهولة على
الفور ، ثم يمكنهم التعرف على
المضايقات والتمييز ، ولكن الأهم من
ذلك أنه يمكنهم تسجيل
ما حدث على الفور ، حيث يرشدك عبر
جميع التفاصيل ثم تحصل على ملف PDF
يمكنك أن تحتفظ بنفسك كيف
حدث ذلك ، هل حدث لك شيئًا شخصيًا أم أن هذا
يتعلق فقط بخلفيتك ،
كل امرأة لديها قصص بعضها أكثر
قسوة من غيرها ، لكنني أعتقد أن
هناك إدراكًا بأننا جميعًا نعيش
في حقائق مختلفة  وأعتقد أنني
أيضًا قد انتهى الوقت وهذه الأنواع من
الحركات تُظهر للعالم حقًا
وتكشف للعالم ماهية هذه
الحقائق المختلفة وللتحرش
وعدم الإبلاغ عن
التحرش في العمل ، أردنا فقط
إنشاء أداة تساعد حقًا في حل
المشكلة التي تمثل جزءًا من
الحل والتي تمكّن الأشخاص من
الإبلاغ
عما يحدث بشكل مجهول وبطريقة آمنة  د